bandera Blanca por la Pascua ortodoxa
con motivo de la festividad religiosa
que une a gran parte de rusos y
ucranianos este domingo ambos bandos del
conflicto llevaron a cabo un intercambio
de prisioneros del lado ruso un número
indeterminado de presos fue entregado
por las fuerzas de kiev mientras que 130
ucranianos volvieron a casa entre ellos
no solo militares sino guardias
fronterizos marineros o miembros de la
guardia nacional
camaradas prisioneros de guerra hoy
recibió órdenes de mi comandancia de
transferirlos al lado ucraniano para la
Pascua para que puedan regresar con sus
familias esposas madres e hijos Espero
que no vuelvan a caer en nuestras manos
mientras la batalla continúa en el
frente este en la estratégica Región del
donbas las autoridades gubernamentales
pidieron que los servicios religiosos
por la Pascua se hicieran en línea pero
en una localidad a 20 km de los combates
el capellá local desafió las
advertencias y ofrecía una misa que
congregó a militares y a civiles por
igual
horario de decir cualquier buena palabra
puede influir en el hecho de que
definitivamente obtendremos nuestra
Victoria eso es inevitable
a poco más de 100 kilómetros de kiev
decenas de feligreses se congregaron en
torno a la iglesia dañada por las tropas
del kremlin y que según los habitantes
sirvió durante semanas como depósito de
municiones todo se quemó Pero no importa
lo más importante es que la iglesia
todavía está aquí la iglesia representa
las almas humanas las personas que
vienen aquí son las que realmente crean
la iglesia misma Ruso y ucranianos
festejaron su día grande de la Pascua
mientras la guerra no da tregua a portas
de cumplirse su décimo cuarto mes
[Música]